- أهلاً بكم مجدداً في "فهم المعلومات
والحوسبة الكمية." اسمي John Watrous، وأنا المدير التقني
لقسم التعليم في IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس الخامس في السلسلة، وهو أول درس في
الوحدة الثانية من السلسلة، والتي تتناول الخوارزميات الكمية.
في هذه الوحدة، سنستكشف
المزايا الحسابية للمعلومات الكمية، أي سنلقي نظرة على
ما يمكننا فعله
بالحواسيب الكمية والمزايا التي يمكن أن تتفوق بها الحواسيب الكمية
على الحواسيب التقليدية.
سنركز على ما يمكننا فعله بحاسوب كمي واحد بدلاً من بيئة
موزعة، مثلاً،
حيث تتفاعل عدة حواسيب كمية عبر شبكة من نوع ما.
هناك بالفعل مزايا كمية يمكن العثور عليها في البيئات الموزعة، حيث يلعب الاتصال
والتشفير دوراً،
لكننا لن نتحدث
عن هذه الأمور في هذه الوحدة.
هذه الوحدة تتناول الخوارزميات الكمية التي تعمل على حواسيب كمية مفردة.
لنبدأ بسؤال طبيعي. ما المزايا التي يمكن أن يقدمها
الحاسوب الكمي؟
الميزة الرئيسية هي أن الحواسيب الكمية قد توفر حلولاً أسرع لبعض المسائل الحسابية.
الوقت ثمين، ورغم أن الحواسيب التي
نستخدمها يومياً سريعة جداً، إلا أنها لا تزال بطيئة جداً
لحل بعض المسائل الحسابية بسبب الصعوبة
الحسابية الكامنة في تلك المسائل.
هذه الإمكانية بأن الحواسيب الكمية قد تسمح لنا بحل مسائل تكون الحواسيب التقليدية
بطيئة جداً لحلها
هي فعلاً ما دفع
أبحاث الخوارزميات الكمية خلال العقود القليلة الماضية.
هناك موارد حسابية
أخرى غير الوقت يمكن أخذها بعين الاعتبار، مثل حجم ذاكرة الحاسوب اللازمة للحسابات،
لكن الحواسيب الكمية لا تستطيع
تقديم توفير كبير من حيث الذاكرة، كما اتضح، وذاكرة الحاسوب
التقليدي رخيصة نسبياً
خصوصاً مقارنة بالذاكرة الكمية. لذا لا يوجد
الكثير من الأمل هنا.
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في موارد أخرى مثل كمية الطاقة
اللازمة للحوسبة، لكن في الواقع لا
تحتاج الكثير من الطاقة
للحوسبة التقليدية، خصوصاً إذا كنت
مستعداً لإبطاء الأمور.
لذا فإن الوقت
اللازم للحسابات هو تركيزنا الرئيسي فعلاً.
إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس، الذي يتناول نموذجاً محدداً
للحوسبة يُعرف بنموذج الاستعلام.
يمكنكم التفكير في هذا النموذج كأنه طبق بتري لتطوير الأفكار الخوارزمية، سواء الكمية أو التقليدية.
لا يُقصد منه أن يكون نموذجاً عملياً يصف أنواع
المسائل الحسابية التي نواجهها في الحياة الواقعية.
سننتقل بعيداً عن نموذج الاستعلام في الدروس اللاحقة من هذه الوحدة ونركز بدلاً من ذلك على نماذج مستوحاة من مفاهيم أكثر عملية
للحوسبة،
لكن نموذج الاستعلام هو
مكان جيد جداً للبدء.
إنه نموذج بسيط يسمح لنا باستكشاف
إمكانات الحواسيب الكمية دون الكثير من التفاصيل
التقنية التي تعترض الطريق،
كما يسمح لنا بعزل بعض
الأفكار المهمة فعلاً وراء الحوسبة الكمية وكيف تعمل.
الحوسبة الكمية تطورت فعلاً في البداية ضمن هذا النموذج، والأفكار التي
تم تطويرها فيه ألهمت بشكل مباشر جداً
خوارزميات كمية مهمة
مثل خوارزمية Shor للتحليل إلى عوامل.
في القسم الأول من الدرس، سنلقي نظرة تحديداً على ما هو نموذج الاستعلام للحوسبة،
وفي القسمين الثاني والثالث
والرابع، سنناقش ثلاث
خوارزميات استعلام كمية، وهي خوارزمية Deutsch،
وخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa،
وخوارزمية Simon، والتي تكشف عن مزايا
متزايدة الإبهار
للحواسيب الكمية
على الحواسيب التقليدية ضمن نموذج الاستعلام للحوسبة.
لشرح نموذج الاستعلام للحوسبة، لنبدأ أولاً بتجريد أكثر
معيارية للحوسبة.
هنا صورة
تمثل حوسبة بمصطلحات بسيطة جداً وأساسية.
لدينا مدخل، والذي عادة يأخذ
شكل سلسلة ثنائية، رغم أنه يمكننا استخدام رموز
أخرى إذا أردنا.
المدخل يُقدَّم للحوسبة، والتي تمثلها مستطيل أزرق
في هذه الصورة،
ونتيجة الحوسبة هي إنتاج مخرج ما، ومرة أخرى، هذا
عادة سلسلة ثنائية.
بالطبع، هذه الصورة
لا تحدد أبداً كيف تعمل الحوسبة نفسها.
يمكننا صياغة نماذج
حسابية محددة مختلفة لذلك، مثل آلات تورنغ
والدوائر البولية،
أو الدوائر الكمية إذا كنا نفكر في
الحوسبة الكمية.
صحيح أن هذه الصورة
لا تمثل حقيقة أن الكثير من الحواسيب التي نستخدمها يومياً تتلقى
مدخلات وتنتج مخرجات باستمرار،
وتتفاعل معنا ومع حواسيب أخرى عبر
الإنترنت، مثلاً.
لكننا لا نحاول تمثيل
تلك التفاعلات هنا.
هذا يتعلق بنمذجة
مهام حسابية معزولة.
مثلاً، قد يكون المدخل هو
الترميز الثنائي لعدد أو تمثيل لمصفوفة
أو وصف لجزيء أو أي شيء آخر نفكر فيه، وهناك مهمة حسابية ما
يتم تنفيذها على ذلك المدخل وحده.
النقطة الأساسية هنا هي
أن المدخل بالكامل يُقدَّم للحوسبة، ولا شيء من
المدخل مخفي عنها.
نموذج الاستعلام
للحوسبة يعمل بشكل مختلف.
في نموذج الاستعلام، المدخل يُتاح
على شكل دالة يمكن للحوسبة
الوصول إليها عبر إجراء استعلامات،
أو بعبارة أخرى، عبر تقييم الدالة
على مدخلات مختلفة.
هنا يمكنكم رؤية ذلك ممثلاً
على شكل صورة.
مشابه لما كان لدينا سابقاً، الحوسبة ممثلة
بمستطيل أزرق، لكن بدلاً من تلقي مدخل مباشرة
على شكل سلسلة
من البتات، مثلاً، تصل إلى المدخل عبر طرح أسئلة
فعلياً وتلقي إجابات.
أحياناً نستخدم
مصطلحي أوراكل وصندوق أسود للإشارة إلى الآلية
التي توفر المدخل.
هناك تمييز بين
الأوراكل والصندوق الأسود في نظرية التعقيد، لكن ذلك لن يكون ذا صلة على الإطلاق لأغراض هذا النقاش.
على أي حال، هذه المصطلحات تهدف
إلى نقل الفكرة الأساسية.
في اليونان القديمة، كان
بإمكانك الذهاب إلى أوراكل، مثل أوراكل دلفي،
وطرح سؤال مهم،
وكان الأوراكل يجيب على
ذلك السؤال المحدد، لكنها بالتأكيد لن تخبرك بكل ما تعرفه.
على نفس المنوال، عندما
نفكر في صندوق أسود، نتصور نوعاً من
العملية أو النظام
حيث يمكننا اختيار ما يدخل ويمكننا رؤية ما يخرج، لكن ليس لدينا أي فهم
لآلية عمله الداخلية.
وهذا هو الحال هنا. المدخل للمسألة
يأخذ شكل دالة، وكل ما يمكننا فعله هو
تقييم تلك الدالة،
لكن بخلاف ذلك، ليس لدينا
أي معرفة أو فهم لكيفية عملها.
طوال الدرس،
سنحجز الحرف f للدالة التي
تمثل المدخل، وسنفترض
أنها دائماً تأخذ
الشكل الذي ترونه هنا.
سيغما تدل على الأبجدية الثنائية، إذن f هي دالة من سلاسل
البتات إلى سلاسل البتات،
وتحديداً، سنفترض
أن مدخل f هو سلسلة بتات بطول n، والمخرج هو سلسلة
بتات بطول m،
حيث n وm أعداد صحيحة موجبة.
لمسائل مختلفة، ستكون
لدينا قيود على n وm، لكن في جميع الحالات، دالة المدخل ستأخذ
شكلاً كهذا.
عندما نقول أن
حوسبة تجري استعلاماً، نعني أن
الدالة f تُقيَّم مرة واحدة،
أي يتم اختيار سلسلة x بطول N من قبل الحوسبة، والسلسلة f(x) تُتاح
لها بعد ذلك
من قبل الأوراكل أو الصندوق الأسود. وأخيراً، الطريقة البسيطة جداً التي سنقيس بها التكلفة الحسابية
لخوارزمية استعلام هي عدّ كم استعلاماً تتطلبه.
إذن، رغم أنه صحيح أننا
مهتمون فعلاً أكثر بالمدة التي تستغرقها الحسابات، عندما ندرس نموذج الاستعلام،
نبقي الأمور
بسيطة ونعدّ الاستعلامات فقط، وهذا ما سنفعله في هذا الدرس.
الآن، لنلقِ نظرة على
بعض أمثلة مسائل الاستعلام، أي المسائل الحسابية
في نموذج الاستعلام،
وهنا، بالمناسبة، سأصف
المسائل نفسها فقط، وفي هذه المرحلة، لن أقول شيئاً
عن كيفية حلها.
المسألة الأولى هي مسألة OR.
في هذه الحالة، المدخل هو دالة
من n بت إلى بت واحد فقط، إذن m يساوي 1 لهذه المسألة،
والمخرج المطلوب للمسألة
هو إما 1 أو 0.
إذا كانت هناك سلسلة x من n بت بحيث f(x) تساوي 1، فالإجابة الصحيحة هي 1،
وبخلاف ذلك، إذا كانت f(x)
دائماً 0 لكل سلسلة x، فالإجابة الصحيحة هي 0.
فإذا فكرنا في الدالة f كأنها توفر لنا وصولاً عشوائياً
إلى 2 أس n بت، واحد لكل سلسلة x من n بت،
فإن ما تطلبه المسألة
هو OR لتلك البتات، ولهذا تُسمى مسألة OR.
مثال آخر هو مسألة التكافؤ، وهي مشابهة لمسألة OR لكنها تسأل عن التكافؤ،
أو بعبارة أخرى، عملية eXclusive OR لجميع قيم المخرجات
ذات البت الواحد للدالة.
طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي
أن الإجابة الصحيحة هي 0 إذا كان عدد سلاسل n بت x التي f(x) تساوي 1 زوجياً،
والإجابة الصحيحة هي
1 إذا كان ذلك العدد فردياً.
مثال على مسألة حيث m ليس بالضرورة يساوي 1 هو مسألة الحد الأدنى.
هنا، الدالة f تأخذ الشكل المعتاد، ولا توجد قيود على n وm،
والإجابة الصحيحة هي أي قيمة مخرجة
للدالة تأتي أولاً في الترتيب المعجمي
أو ترتيب القاموس
للسلاسل الثنائية. بدلاً من ذلك، إذا أردتم
التفكير في السلاسل بطول m كأنها تمثل أعداداً صحيحة
غير سالبة بالتدوين الثنائي،
فالإجابة الصحيحة
هي أصغر قيمة ممكنة أو الحد الأدنى الذي
يخرج من هذه الدالة.
أحياناً نأخذ بعين الاعتبار أيضاً مسائل استعلام حيث لدينا وعد
على دالة المدخل، أو بعبارة أخرى، نوع من
الضمان عليها،
ولا نقلق بشأن الدوال التي لا تستوفي ذلك الوعد.
الدوال التي لا تستوفي الوعد تُعتبر مدخلات "لا تهمنا".
ونحن ببساطة غير مسؤولين عما يحدث مع تلك المدخلات.
إليكم مثالاً على مسألة استعلام بوعد تُسمى البحث الفريد.
إنها مرتبطة بمسألة OR،
لكنها مختلفة.
دالة المدخل لها نفس
الشكل كما في مسألة OR، وهي أنها تأخذ
سلاسل n بت إلى بتات.
هذه المرة، نحن موعودون بأن
هناك سلسلة واحدة بالضبط Z تجعل f تُقيَّم بـ 1،
حيث f(x) تساوي 0
لكل سلسلة x غير z، والمخرج الصحيح
هو هذه السلسلة الفريدة z.
بالطبع، هناك
خيارات للدالة f لا تستوفي هذا الشرط، لكننا لا نضع أي متطلبات على الإطلاق
على الخوارزميات لهذه المسألة عندما تُعطى مثل هذه
الدوال كمدخلات.
نحن نهتم فقط بالدوال التي تستوفي الوعد.
الآن، المسائل الأربع
التي ذكرتها للتو هي مسائل طبيعية جداً، بمعنى أنه من السهل شرحها،
ومن السهل تخيل مواقف قد تنشأ فيها حاجة لحلها، لكن بعض مسائل الاستعلام
ليست كذلك على الإطلاق.
في الواقع، أحياناً نأخذ بعين الاعتبار مسائل
استعلام مصطنعة جداً، حيث يصعب تخيل أن أي شخص سيرغب
فعلاً في حلها.
مسألة Simon، التي سنراها
لاحقاً في الدرس، تندرج نوعاً ما ضمن هذه الفئة، لكن هناك بعض المسائل الأخرى
التي هي أسوأ بكثير بمعنى ما، لكنها مع ذلك تتضح أنها مهمة جداً لدراسة نموذج الاستعلام.
نحن لا ندرس هذه المسائل لأننا نريد بالضرورة
حلها عملياً.
الطريقة التي يمكنكم التفكير بها هي أننا نبحث عن
الحالات القصوى بأنواعها المختلفة،
وبالتحديد، عندما نعمل ضمن
هذا النموذج الشبيه بطبق بتري، فإن طريقة طبيعية لاستكشاف
الأفكار الخوارزمية الكمية
هي صياغة مسائل مصطنعة جداً، حيث يمكننا استغلال
قوة الحواسيب الكمية بأفضل شكل.
وهذا يمكن فعلاً
أن يسلط ضوءاً كبيراً على كيف يمكن للحواسيب الكمية
أن تكون مفيدة في بيئات أكثر عملية.
يمكننا إضفاء الطابع الرسمي على
مفهوم الاستعلام بطرق مختلفة حسب النموذج
الحسابي الذي نعمل به.
مثلاً، في نموذج
آلة تورنغ للحوسبة، الذي لم نتحدث عنه ولن ندخل فيه في هذه السلسلة،
هناك طريقة معينة
لإضفاء الطابع الرسمي على مفهوم الاستعلام تكون منطقية لذلك النموذج.
لنماذج الدوائر، نعرّف أنواعاً خاصة من
البوابات تُسمى بوابات الاستعلام، وهكذا تُمثَّل الاستعلامات
رسمياً.
للدوائر البولية، هناك طريقة بسيطة جداً للقيام بذلك، وهي ببساطة تخيل
أن لدينا بوابات استعلام
تُقيّم دالة المدخل مباشرة، كما ترون هنا على الشاشة.
الفكرة هي أنه يمكننا
استخدام بوابات الاستعلام هذه لبناء دوائر تحل أي
مسألة ننظر إليها،
ولكي تعمل بشكل صحيح، يجب أن تعطي الدوائر الإجابة الصحيحة لأي دالة مدخل f مُعطاة،
على افتراض أنها تستوفي الوعد في حالة مسألة الوعد.
إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً
على دائرة بولية تحل مسألة التكافؤ
عندما n يساوي 1،
إذن دالة المدخل f هي من
بت واحد إلى بت واحد في هذه الحالة.
ما تفعله هذه الدائرة هو تقييم الدالة
f على المدخلات 0 و1 باستخدام بوابتي الاستعلام هاتين.
ثم تُدخل قيمتي المخرجات اللتين تحصل عليهما
من بوابات الاستعلام في الدائرة البولية من الدرس الثالث التي تحسب XOR،
وهو نفس الشيء مثل التكافؤ.
للتوضيح، هاتان
القيمتان المدخلتان هنا ليستا مدخلات للمسألة،
أي مسألة التكافؤ،
عندما نعمل مع نموذج الاستعلام، المدخل للمسألة
هو الدالة f، ويجب أن تفكروا في هذين
المدخلين للدائرة
كقيم مُثبتة
لا تتغير أبداً، إنها أساساً جزء من الخوارزمية.
نريد حساب XOR لـ f(0) وf(1)، لذلك قمنا بتهيئة هذين
السلكين بهذه الطريقة
لجعلها تعمل. استخدمنا بوابتي استعلام
هنا، هذه وهذه،
وبالتالي الخوارزمية الممثلة
بهذه الدائرة البولية تُجري استعلامين، وإذا فكرنا في مسألة
التكافؤ للحظة
للدوال من بت واحد إلى بت واحد، نرى أنه من الضروري تماماً لأي دائرة بولية
تحل هذه المسألة
أن تُجري استعلامين على الأقل.
إذا أجريت استعلاماً واحداً فقط بحيث تعرف قيمة مخرج واحدة
فقط من الدالة f وليس الأخرى، فأنت فعلاً لا تملك
أي معلومات على الإطلاق
عن التكافؤ، لأن قيمة المخرج الأخرى
يمكن أن تكون 0 أو 1 بالتساوي، مما يؤدي إلى أي من
الحلين الممكنين
للمسألة. لذا من حيث عدد
الاستعلامات التي تُجريها، هذه الدائرة البولية هي أفضل ما يمكن تحقيقه
لمسألة التكافؤ
عندما n يساوي 1.
هناك نقطة أخرى حول بوابات الاستعلام تستحق الذكر قبل أن ننتقل، وهي أنه عندما نصمم ونحلل خوارزميات الاستعلام،
لا نقلق أبداً بشأن كيفية
تنفيذ بوابات الاستعلام.
يُفترض أن بوابات
الاستعلام هذه مُعطاة لنا، وصعوبة بنائها
ليست من شأننا.
يمكنكم التفكير في
بوابات الاستعلام نفسها كأنها المدخل إذا أردتم، وليس من وظيفتنا إعداد المدخل، نحن فقط نحاول
حل مسألة معينة
بالنظر إلى المدخل. بالطبع، عندما تكون f دالة
من بت واحد إلى بت واحد، هناك أربعة خيارات ممكنة فقط،
وسيكون من السهل تنفيذ
أي منها، لكن بشكل عام، للدوال
ذات البتات المدخلة الكثيرة،
قد يكون من الصعب للغاية تنفيذ بوابات الاستعلام
لتلك الدوال.
للتوضيح، هذا لا يعني
أن مسألة كيفية تنفيذ بوابات الاستعلام
ليست مهمة، بل إنها لا تُعتبر
جزءاً من تكلفة
خوارزمية الاستعلام.
هذا يتسق مع فكرة أن هذا ليس فعلاً
عن الحوسبة العملية أو بناء الدوائر بحد ذاتها،
إنه عن العمل ضمن
إطار نظري يخبرنا بأشياء مثيرة
للاهتمام عن الحوسبة.
سيكون لدينا المزيد لنقوله عن هذا عندما ننتقل من هذا النموذج إلى نموذج أكثر معيارية للحوسبة، وهذا أساساً ما سيتناوله الدرس التالي،
الدرس 6.
الآن لننقل انتباهنا
إلى الدوائر الكمية.
للدوائر الكمية، سنغير
تعريف بوابات الاستعلام لجعلها أحادية.
نريد أن نكون قادرين على إجراء
استعلامات ضمن الدوائر الكمية وأن تعمل
خطياً على الحالات الكمية
بحيث يمكننا فعلياً
إجراء استعلامات في تراكب.
قد يبدو أننا ننقل
خط المرمى، إذا جاز التعبير، بتغيير ما نعنيه بالاستعلام مقارنة بما رأيناه
للتو للدوائر البولية،
لكن هناك تبرير لذلك سنناقشه بمزيد من
التفصيل في الدرس التالي.
في الوقت الحالي، إنه مجرد تعريف.
تحديداً، التعريف
هو كالتالي، لأي دالة f بنفس
الشكل السابق،
بمعنى أنها تربط سلاسل
n بت بسلاسل m بت، فإن بوابة الاستعلام Uf تعمل على n + m من الـ qubits
وتُعرَّف بالفعل
الموصوف هنا على حالات الأساس المعيارية.
سنرى شكلاً
يمثل هذا التعريف بعد لحظات، لكن أولاً، دعوني أوضح الترميز
المُستخدم هنا،
وهو أنه كلما
استخدمنا رمز XOR كعملية بين سلسلتين
من نفس الطول،
فإننا نشير إلى
عملية eXclusive OR بتية، وهنا يمكنكم رؤية مثال.
في التعريف، لدينا أن كلاً من y وf(x)
هما سلسلتان بطول m، لذا هذه السلسلة هنا
تمثل السلسلة التي نحصل عليها
عبر تطبيق XOR على هاتين السلسلتين
معاً، بت ببت، وهنا المخطط
الذي يشرح كيف تعمل هذه البوابات.
الـ n qubits العلوية تتوافق مع
وسيط الدالة.
وعندما تبدأ في
حالة أساس معيارية، cat x في هذا المخطط، تمر حالة الأساس المعيارية تلك
دون تغيير
وتُعكَس كجزء من المخرج.
الـ m qubits السفلية تتوافق مع مخرج
الدالة f، وعندما تبدأ في
أي حالة أساس معيارية،
cat y في هذا المخطط، ما يحدث هو أن
مخرج الدالة f(x) يُطبَّق عليه XOR مع السلسلة y.
هذا ما يحدث مع
حالات الأساس المعيارية، وإذا أردنا معرفة
ما يحدث بشكل عام لحالات كمية أخرى،
نستخدم الخطية، كما نفعل دائماً.
سبب تعريف بوابات الاستعلام بهذا الشكل حيث نعكس المدخل ونستخدم XOR البتي للمخرج
هو أن هذه البوابات تكون دائماً أحادية لأي اختيار للدالة f.
هذه في الواقع عملية
حتمية.
وإذا أردنا التعبير عنها كمصفوفة لأي اختيار للدالة F، سنحصل على مصفوفة تبديل،
بمعنى أن فيها واحد وحيد في كل صف وكل عمود، وجميع المدخلات الأخرى تساوي 0.
ومصفوفات التبديل
تكون دائماً أحادية.
في الواقع، لهذه العملية، سنحصل على أن العملية
هي معكوسها الذاتي، إذن Uf المرافقة تساوي Uf.
إذا كان كل ما نريد فعله بهذه
البوابات هو تقييم f(x) لسلسلة x ما، فهذا سهل،
يمكننا ببساطة تعيين y
لتكون سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل. فعندما نأخذ XOR لـ y نحصل على f(x) فقط.
هنا، بالمناسبة، يمكنكم رؤية الترميز المُستخدم للدلالة على سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل.
يبدو مثل 0 أس M، لكن هذا ليس معناه.
إنه يعني سلسلة الأصفار
بطول يساوي M.
عندما نتحدث عن
السلاسل بدلاً من الأعداد، الأسس عادة تعني أننا نكرر تلك السلسلة
عدداً من المرات،
إذن هذا هو 0 مكرر m مرة.
إنها طريقة مريحة ودقيقة لوصف هذه السلسلة.
مرة أخرى، عندما
نعمل مع نموذج الاستعلام، لا نقلق بشأن كيفية
تنفيذ بوابات الاستعلام هذه.
هذه نفس المسألة
التي كانت لدينا مع بوابات الاستعلام للدوائر البولية.
ليس من وظيفتنا إعداد المدخل، نحن نُعطى المدخل على شكل
بوابات الاستعلام هذه.
سأنوّه رغم ذلك، أنه إذا عرفنا كيف نُنفّذ
الدالة f باستخدام دائرة بولية، فمن الممكن
ترجمة ذلك التنفيذ
بشكل مباشر إلى حد كبير إلى تنفيذ
دائرة كمية لـ Uf، وسنرى بالضبط كيف
يعمل ذلك في الدرس التالي.
كملاحظة جانبية، من السهل جداً إنشاء دائرة بولية
تعمل بهذا الشكل، باستخدام بوابة استعلام
تقليدية واحدة للدالة f،
لكن هذا مختلف تماماً عن وجود
تنفيذ دائرة كمية لهذه البوابة الأحادية.
النقطة مع ذلك هي أنه
بالنسبة لخوارزميات الاستعلام التقليدية، وجود بوابة استعلام تعمل بهذا الشكل هو في الواقع مكافئ
لوجود بوابة استعلام
تقليدية عادية لـ f، بمعنى أنه يمكن تنفيذ أي منهما باستخدام الأخرى.
في هذا القسم من الدرس، سنناقش خوارزمية Deutsch، وهي خوارزمية
استعلام كمية بسيطة جداً، لكنها فعلاً جوهرة.
هذه الخوارزمية تأتي من ورقة بحثية عام 1985 كتبها David Deutsch، الذي كان من أوائل الأشخاص الذين عملوا على الأسس النظرية
للحوسبة الكمية.
الخوارزمية نفسها تمثل جزءاً صغيراً جداً
من ورقة Deutsch عام 1985، وفي الواقع،
الخوارزمية التي نسميها الآن
خوارزمية Deutsch هي فعلاً نسخة محسّنة من الخوارزمية التي وصفها Deutsch.
إنها توفر مثالاً متواضعاً جداً على كيف يمكن للحواسيب الكمية أن
تقدم مزايا حسابية، لكن عليك أن تبدأ من مكان ما،
وقد كانت فعلاً شرارة مهمة أطلقت الأمور.
خوارزمية Deutsch تحل مسألة استعلام تُسمى غالباً مسألة Deutsch في سياق الحوسبة الكمية،
لكنها في الواقع ليست سوى
مسألة التكافؤ للدوال من بت واحد إلى بت واحد، والتي تحدثنا عنها بالفعل.
كما رأينا بالفعل، هناك أربع دوال
من بت واحد إلى بت واحد، وهي موصوفة هنا على الشاشة بجداول قيمها.
الأولى والأخيرة من هذه
الدوال ثابتة، بينما الوسطيتان متوازنتان بمعنى أن قيمتي
المخرج الممكنتين
تظهران نفس العدد من المرات.
للدالتين الثابتتين،
نرى أن التكافؤ، أو بعبارة أخرى، eXclusive OR للمخرجين هو 0،
وللدالتين المتوازنتين، تكافؤ المخرجات هو 1.
إذن طريقة مكافئة
لوصف مسألة التكافؤ في هذه الحالة بالذات، حيث الدالة f تأخذ
بتاً واحداً كمدخل،
أو بعبارة أخرى، مسألة Deutsch، هي كما ترون هنا.
المدخل هو دالة f
من بت واحد إلى بت واحد، والمخرج هو 0 إذا كانت f ثابتة
و1 إذا كانت f متوازنة.
كما أشرت بالفعل، كل خوارزمية استعلام تقليدية
تحل هذه المسألة يجب أن تُجري استعلامين على الأقل لـ f.
إذا عرفت قيمة مخرج واحدة
فقط من القيمتين لـ f، فلا تزال لا تملك أي معلومات على الإطلاق عن تكافؤ المخرجين.
وهذا، بالمناسبة، صحيح
حتى للخوارزميات التقليدية التي تستخدم العشوائية.
العشوائية يمكن أحياناً أن تكون مفيدة جداً لحل مسائل الاستعلام، وسنرى مثالاً
لاحقاً في الدرس،
لكن العشوائية لا تساعد هنا.
إذن خوارزميتنا السابقة هي الأمثل بين خوارزميات الاستعلام التقليدية
لمسألة Deutsch.
الآن سنلقي نظرة
على خوارزمية Deutsch، وهي خوارزمية استعلام كمية تحل مسألة
Deutsch باستخدام استعلام واحد.
وهنا الخوارزمية
موصوفة كدائرة كمية.
لدينا qubit-ان
مُهيّآن كما ترون هنا، العلوي مُهيّأ على cat 0 والسفلي مُهيّأ على cat 1،
وسنرى لماذا نُهيّئ هذين الـ qubits بهذا الشكل قريباً.
نُطبّق بوابات Hadamard
على الـ qubit-ين، نُدخلهما في بوابة الاستعلام، نُطبّق بوابة Hadamard
أخرى على الـ qubit العلوي،
ثم نقيسه. والادعاء هو أن
نتيجة القياس تعطينا، بيقين، الإجابة
الصحيحة للمسألة.
إذن لنحلل
الدائرة خطوة بخطوة لنرى بالضبط كيف تعمل.
حالة الـ qubit-ين بعد الطبقة الأولى من بوابات Hadamard هي الجداء التنسوري لحالتي
الناقص والزائد.
بوابة Hadamard العلوية تحوّل
حالة 0 إلى حالة زائد، وبوابة Hadamard السفلية تحوّل حالة 1 إلى حالة ناقص.
الـ qubit العلوي على اليمين، والـ qubit السفلي على اليسار، إذن هذه هي الحالة التي نحصل عليها.
من المهم جداً أن الـ qubit السفلي في حالة ناقص، بالمناسبة، هذا لن يعمل إذا
هيّأنا الـ qubit السفلي
على حالة 0 بدلاً من حالة 1.
سنفك هذه الحالة
جزئياً، كما ترون هنا.
سبب فعل ذلك
ليس واضحاً في هذه المرحلة، لكنه سيكون مريحاً
بعد لحظات.
بعد ذلك، لنفكر في
حالة الـ qubit-ين بعد تطبيق بوابة الاستعلام.
طريقة عمل بوابة الاستعلام
هي أنها تحسب F على حالة الأساس المعيارية
للـ qubit العلوي وتُطبّق XOR على القيمة
إلى الـ qubit السفلي،
وهنا يمكننا رؤية
نتيجة فعل ذلك.
بالنسبة للحد الأول، حالة الأساس المعيارية
للـ qubit العلوي هي 0، إذن f(0) يُطبّق عليها XOR
إلى الـ qubit السفلي،
وهذا يعمل بالخطية. والأمر مشابه للحد الثاني، إلا أن حالة الأساس المعيارية
للـ qubit العلوي هي 1، لذا نُطبّق XOR لـ f(1) على الـ qubit السفلي.
وفي هذه المرحلة، يمكننا
تبسيط هذا التعبير بملاحظة الصيغة
التي ترونها هنا في الأسفل، والتي تعمل عندما a تكون إما 0 أو 1.
ويمكننا ببساطة التحقق من ذلك لهاتين القيمتين بشكل منفصل.
إذا كانت a تساوي 0، فتطبيق
XOR مع a لا يفعل شيئاً، وسالب 1 أس 0 يساوي 1،
إذن الطرفان متساويان. وإذا كانت a تساوي 1، نحصل على cat 1 ناقص cat
0 عند أخذ XOR،
وهو سالب 1
مضروباً في cat 0 ناقص cat 1.
وإذا استخدمنا تلك الصيغة
لتبسيط حالتنا، حيث نأخذ a تساوي
f(0) على اليسار وa تساوي f(1) على اليمين،
نحصل على التعبير
الذي ترونه هنا.
فعندما نقارن متجهي
الحالة الكمية π1 وπ2، نرى أن ما تفعله بوابة Uf
هو فعلياً وضع
إحدى القيمتين، f(0) أو f(1)، في
أس سالب 1،
أو بعبارة أخرى، في
الطور لكل حد.
هذا هو السبب في
تهيئة الـ qubit السفلي على 1 وتطبيق بوابة Hadamard عليه لإنشاء حالة الناقص،
مما يسمح لهذا بالحدوث.
تُسمى ظاهرة ارتداد الطور، وسنعود إليها بعد لحظات لنلقي نظرة أخرى عليها.
إنها مهمة جداً، وسنراها تحدث
مرات أخرى في الدرس، وكذلك في الدروس اللاحقة.
يمكننا الآن التبسيط بسحب
حالة الناقص للخارج مرة أخرى للحصول على التعبير
الذي ترونه هنا.
كملاحظة جانبية، من المثير
ملاحظة أنه لا يوجد فعلاً
أي تشابك هنا.
كلتا الحالتين هما حالتا جداء. إذن، حسناً، التشابك
مثير للغاية،
لكنه لا يلعب
أي دور على الإطلاق في هذه الخوارزمية بالذات.
لنُنظّف هذا قليلاً حتى يكون لدينا مساحة أكبر.
ما يمكننا فعله الآن هو
سحب عامل سالب 1 مرفوعاً لأس f(0) للخارج
للحصول على تعبير الحالة
الذي ترونه هنا.
ستلاحظون أن هنا لدينا eXclusive OR لـ f(0) وf(1) في أس سالب 1.
قد نتوقع أن يكون
f(1) ناقص f(0) لأننا سحبنا عامل سالب 1 أس f(0) للخارج،
لكننا نحصل على نفس
القيمة إذا أخذنا XOR لأن هذه بتات، والشيء الوحيد المهم عندما يكون لدينا عدد صحيح في
أس سالب 1
هو ما إذا كان ذلك العدد الصحيح زوجياً أم فردياً.
طريقة أخرى للتعبير عن
هذه الحالة هي كما لدينا هنا، حيث نأخذ بعين الاعتبار فقط
الحالتين الممكنتين لـ XOR.
وهذه طريقة مريحة
للتعبير عن الحالة عندما نأخذ بعين الاعتبار تأثير
بوابة Hadamard الأخيرة مع القياس.
عندما نُطبّق بوابة Hadamard
الأخيرة على الـ qubit العلوي، تتحول حالة الزائد
إلى حالة 0
وتتحول حالة الناقص
إلى حالة 1، ويمكننا كتابة ذلك بشكل
أكثر اختصاراً هكذا.
وأخيراً، عندما يتم
إجراء القياس، النتيجة التي نحصل عليها هي
إذن XOR لـ f(0) وf(1)،
وهي القيمة التي نبحث عنها، وهكذا تعمل خوارزمية Deutsch.
إنها بسيطة جداً، وإذا سألنا أنفسنا ما
الذي يجعلها تعمل، مما يسمح لنا بحساب
تكافؤ بتين
باستعلام واحد بدلاً من اثنين، فالإجابة المعقولة هي
التداخل.
نحن فعلياً
نحسب f(0) وf(1) في نفس الوقت، لأننا أولاً طبّقنا
بوابة Hadamard
على الـ qubit العلوي لوضع المدخل إلى f في
تراكب من 0 و1.
وبواسطة ارتداد الطور مع بوابة Hadamard الأخيرة، نُنشئ أساساً
تداخلاً بنّاءً
للإجابة الصحيحة وتداخلاً هدّاماً
للإجابة الخاطئة.
لذا لا نرى الإجابة الخاطئة، نرى فقط الإجابة الصحيحة.
دعوني أقول المزيد عن ظاهرة ارتداد الطور لنراها من
زاوية مختلفة قليلاً.
أولاً، لنلاحظ
هذه الصيغة البسيطة جداً حيث b وc قيم ثنائية عشوائية.
باختصار، تطبيق XOR على بت b بالقيمة 1 هو نفس الشيء مثل تطبيق بوابة NOT أو عملية x على b،
وبالطبع، تطبيق XOR
على بت b بالقيمة 0 لا يفعل شيئاً له، وهو نفس الشيء مثل تطبيق
عملية الهوية عليه.
ويمكننا التعبير عن عملية الهوية كـ x أس 0.
فإذا طبّقنا بوابة Uf على qubit-ين في حالة الأساس المعيارية
cat b منسوراً بـ cat a،
نحصل على هذه النتيجة، فقط من تعريف بوابة Uf.
وباستخدام الصيغة، يمكننا كتابة تلك الحالة بشكل بديل كما ترون هنا.
هذه الصيغة تعمل لجميع اختيارات b، لذا بالخطية، تعمل
لحالة عشوائية SI
بدلاً من cat b.
وبالتحديد، إذا أردنا، يمكننا اختيار SI لتكون حالة الناقص.
والآن هنا المفتاح لفهم لماذا تحدث ظاهرة
ارتداد الطور x.
السبب هو أن عملية x
المُطبّقة على حالة الناقص تعطينا سالب 1 مضروباً في حالة الناقص.
بمصطلحات رياضية، نقول أن حالة الناقص
هي متجه ذاتي لعملية x، بقيمة ذاتية تساوي سالب 1.
المتجهات الذاتية والقيم الذاتية
مهمة للغاية في الجبر الخطي وكذلك
في المعلومات الكمية، وسيكون لدينا الكثير
لنقوله عنها
مع استمرار السلسلة.
لكن في الوقت الحالي، كل ما
نحتاجه هو هذه الصيغة البسيطة.
وباستخدامها، يمكننا
تبسيط متجه حالتنا.
وهذا هو أساساً ظاهرة ارتداد
الطور مكتوبة كصيغة.
إنها تعمل لأن حالة الناقص
هي متجه ذاتي لعملية NOT بقيمة
ذاتية سالب واحد.
سنُعمّم هذا بشكل
كبير جداً في الدرس 7، عندما ننتقل إلى إجراء تقدير
الطور، وهو ما يقود
خوارزمية Shor للتحليل إلى عوامل.
يمكننا رؤية هذه الصيغة تعمل في تحليل خوارزمية Deutsch
كالتالي.
قبل بوابة الاستعلام، حالتنا هي الجداء التنسوري لحالتي الناقص والزائد.
ثم نُطبّق بوابة الاستعلام، وتفكيك حالة
الزائد يعطينا هذه الحالة.
نُطبّق الآن صيغة ارتداد الطور للحصول على هذا التعبير، ثم يستمر التحليل
كما سبق.
إنه نفس الشيء كما سبق، لكن هنا نركّز فقط
على ارتداد الطور حتى نتمكن من التعرف عليه
ونكون أيضاً مستعدين له
عندما يظهر مرة أخرى.
بعد ذلك سننتقل إلى
خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa، وهي امتداد
لخوارزمية Deutsch تحل فعلاً عدة
مسائل استعلام مختلفة.
الميزة التي توفرها
خوارزمية Deutsch على الخوارزميات التقليدية
متواضعة جداً، استعلام واحد مقابل اثنين.
خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa تزيد تلك الميزة إلى حد ما، وسأشرح ما أعنيه
بذلك عندما نصل إلى هناك.
يمكن النظر إلى خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa كطريقة طبيعية ومباشرة لتوسيع خوارزمية Deutsch
من الدوال من بت واحد إلى بت واحد إلى الدوال من n بت إلى بت واحد، أو بعبارة أخرى، دوال بهذا الشكل.
كدائرة كمية، خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa
تبدو هكذا، وسأشير إلى هذه
باسم دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa
فقط لرسم تمييز بسيط
بين هذه الدائرة وخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa نفسها لأن هناك أيضاً خطوة
معالجة لاحقة تقليدية.
الفكرة هي أنه إذا شغّلنا
هذه الدائرة ثم قسنا، سنحصل على سلسلة n بت y
تخبرنا شيئاً
عن الدالة f.
في هذه المرحلة، بالمناسبة، لم أقل فعلاً
ما هي مسألة الاستعلام التي قد نأمل في
حلها بهذه الدائرة، ذلك قادم قريباً جداً.
لكن النقطة هي أنه
بتشغيل هذه الدائرة، سنكتسب بعض المعلومات عن f التي يمكن أن تساعدنا
في حل مسائل الاستعلام
حيث f هي المدخل. وكما قلت قبل لحظة، يمكننا فعلاً استخدام هذه الدائرة
لحل عدة
مسائل استعلام مختلفة.
أولاً، لنلقِ نظرة
على مسألة الاستعلام المعروفة باسم مسألة Deutsch-Jozsa، وهي المسألة التي
كان المقصود من دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa
حلها في الأصل.
مسألة Deutsch-Jozsa هي تعميم لمسألة Deutsch، حيث الهدف هو تحديد ما إذا كانت الدالة المُعطاة
ثابتة أم متوازنة.
لاحظوا أن هذه ليست الطريقة الطبيعية لتعميم مسألة التكافؤ
إلى دوال بهذا الشكل.
هنا لا نحسب التكافؤ، المهمة هي إخراج 0 إذا
كانت الدالة f ثابتة
و1 إذا كانت الدالة f متوازنة.
أول شيء يُلاحَظ حول
هذه المسألة هو أنه عندما n، عدد بتات المدخل
للدالة f، يكون على الأقل 2،
هناك خيارات للدالة ليست ثابتة ولا متوازنة.
مثلاً، هنا دالة
من 2 بت إلى 1 بت ليست ثابتة ولا متوازنة.
إنها ليست ثابتة لأن كلتا القيمتين الثنائيتين
تظهران بين المخرجات، وليست متوازنة
لأن قيمتي المخرج
تظهران بتكرارات مختلفة. 0 تظهر ثلاث مرات
و1 تظهر مرة واحدة فقط.
لكي تكون متوازنة،
يجب أن يظهر المخرجان 0 و1 بالضبط
نفس العدد من المرات.
حقيقة وجود دوال ليست ثابتة ولا متوازنة عندما n يكون على الأقل 2 لا بأس بها رغم ذلك، سنعتبر
الدوال هكذا
كمدخلات "لا تهمنا". أو بعبارة أخرى، هذه
مسألة وعد.
وهنا صياغة دقيقة
للمسألة.
نحن موعودون بأن دالة المدخل f إما ثابتة أو متوازنة، والهدف هو معرفة
أيهما.
ولسنا مسؤولين عما يحدث إذا لم يستوفِ المدخل
الوعد.
خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa،
التي تحل هذه المسألة، هي أولاً تشغيل دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa ثم إخراج 0
إذا كانت السلسلة التي
نحصل عليها من القياسات هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل
وإخراج 1 بخلاف ذلك.
طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أننا نُخرج OR
للبتات التي نقيسها.
لتحليل خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa، سيكون من المفيد
التوقف لبضع لحظات للتفكير في بوابات Hadamard.
يمكننا بالطبع وصف عملية Hadamard
كمصفوفة، لكن يمكننا أيضاً وصفها
من حيث تأثيرها
على حالات الأساس المعيارية،
كما ترون هنا.
يمكن دمج هاتين المعادلتين
في معادلة واحدة، تصف كيف تعمل عملية
Hadamard عندما تكون a أياً من
القيمتين الثنائيتين،
ويمكننا الذهاب أبعد قليلاً والتعبير عما
نحصل عليه كمجموع هكذا.
باستخدام تلك الصيغة، يمكننا التوصل إلى صيغة تصف كيف تعمل طبقة
من بوابات Hadamard، حيث نُطبّق بوابة Hadamard
واحدة على كل من n qubit.
هنا نصف هذا
التأثير على حالات الأساس المعيارية.
وللتوضيح حول الترميز، عندما نكتب h منسور n هكذا، حيث جزء المنسور n هو رمز علوي،
نعني الجداء التنسوري n-المرات
لـ H مع نفسها، أو بعبارة أخرى، n نسخة
من h جميعها متنسورة معاً.
نُطبّق هذه العملية
على حالة أساس معيارية، وهنا أتبع
الاصطلاح الذي تستخدمه Qiskit
لفهرسة السلاسل الثنائية، فقط لأنه وقت مناسب
لتقديم هذا الاصطلاح.
إذن x0 هي بت، x1 هي بت،
وهكذا مع n بت إجمالاً، والبتات مرتبة كما
ترون هنا على الشاشة.
يمكنكم التفكير في هذه
الطريقة لفهرسة البتات كأنها تتوافق مع أهميتها إذا نظرنا إلى السلاسل كأنها تمثل
أعداداً صحيحة
بالتدوين الثنائي، مثلاً.
إذا طبّقنا بوابة Hadamard
على كل من هذه الـ qubits، يمكننا بدلاً من ذلك التعبير عن النتيجة كالجداء التنسوري n-المرات
لبوابة Hadamard مُطبّقة على كل qubit، ثم يمكننا تطبيق صيغتنا على كل عامل من عوامل المنسور.
وهنا نستخدم الأسماء
y وسالب 1 نزولاً إلى y1 بدلاً من b في الصيغة،
إذن هذه قيم ثنائية. ونتأكد من استخدام اسم جديد في كل مرة نستخدم فيها الصيغة.
إذا فككنا كل شيء بعد ذلك باستخدام الخطية المتعددة
للجداءات التنسورية، نحصل على التعبير
الذي ترونه هنا.
وللتوضيح، المجاميع n يتم
دمجها في مجموع واحد، لكننا لا نزال نجمع
على جميع القيم الممكنة
للقيم الثنائية الفردية.
الآن لنُنظّف الأمور حتى نتمكن من الذهاب أبعد قليلاً.
والخطوة التالية هي
تقديم عملية جديدة على السلاسل تُسمى الجداء النقطي الثنائي.
هذه عملية على سلاسل ثنائية لها نفس الطول.
والجداء النقطي الثنائي لسلسلتين x وy
بنفس الطول هو eXclusive OR أو تكافؤ
جداءات البتات الفردية.
يمكنكم أيضاً قول أنه XOR لعملية AND المنطقية للبتات الفردية، لأن AND هو
نفس الشيء مثل الجداء
للقيم الثنائية. طريقة أخرى لوصف ذلك
هي أنه 1 أو 0
حسب ما إذا كان
مجموع جداءات البتات الفردية فردياً أو زوجياً.
إنه يشبه كثيراً الجداء الداخلي إذا فكرنا في السلاسل
كمتجهات لقيم ثنائية، لكن حيث نحسب معامل-2،
أو بعبارة أخرى، نأخذ الباقي بعد القسمة على 2.
إنه ليس فعلاً جداءً داخلياً، لذا يستحق اسماً مختلفاً.
في الحالة المطروحة، يمكننا استخدام الجداء النقطي
الثنائي لجعل صيغتنا لتأثير طبقة من بوابات Hadamard
على حالات الأساس المعيارية أكثر اختصاراً، وها هي هنا.
نستخدم حقيقة أنه
لأن هذا المجموع هنا يظهر في
أس سالب 1،
كل ما يهم هو ما إذا كان
زوجياً أم فردياً، لكن بخلاف ذلك، إنها أساساً نسخة مختصرة
من صيغتنا.
بالمناسبة، الجداء النقطي
الثنائي متماثل بمعنى أن x نقطة
y وy نقطة x متساويان،
لذا نحن أحرار في تبديل
الترتيب متى كان ذلك مفيداً.
والآن بعد أن لدينا تلك الصيغة، سيكون من السهل جداً تحليل
دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa.
نبدأ بـ n qubit في حالة 0 والـ qubit السفلي في حالة 1، ونُطبّق بوابات Hadamard
على الجميع.
إذن هذه هي حالة الـ
n + 1 qubit التي نحصل عليها.
نعامل الـ qubit
السفلي بشكل منفصل لأن ذلك سيكون مريحاً.
ومرة أخرى، سنرى ظاهرة ارتداد
الطور تحدث.
يمكننا الحصول على هذا التعبير
باستخدام صيغتنا، حيث نُعوّض
سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل بدلاً من x ونُعوّض x بدلاً من y،
مع ملاحظة أن الجداء النقطي
الثنائي لسلسلة الأصفار بالكامل مع أي سلسلة هو 0.
لكن يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في هذا مباشرة. نأخذ الجداء
التنسوري لـ n حالة زائد، وهذا ما نحصل عليه،
منسوراً بحالة الناقص. ثم تُطبّق بوابة UF، وهنا تحدث ظاهرة ارتداد
الطور.
القيمة f(x) يُطبّق عليها XOR
على حالة الناقص لكل x في المجموع.
إذن f(x) ترتد إلى الطور.
نُطبّق الآن طبقة
أخرى من بوابات Hadamard فقط على الـ n qubits العلوية، وهذه المرة نحتاج
الصيغة فعلاً.
وعندما نُطبّقها ونقوم بقليل
من التبسيط، نحصل على هذه الحالة هنا.
إذن هذه هي حالتنا النهائية قبل
القياسات مباشرة.
الحالة تبدو معقدة بعض الشيء، ومن الصعب تبسيطها لأننا لا نعرف فعلاً
شيئاً عن الدالة f.
لكن تذكروا، كل
ما نحتاج معرفته فعلاً هو ما إذا كانت القياسات
تعطي جميعها النتيجة 0 أم لا،
لأن ذلك هو ما يحدد إجابتنا للمسألة.
إذا رأينا أن كل
نتيجة قياس هي 0، نستنتج أن الدالة ثابتة.
وإذا كانت أي واحدة من
نتائج القياس هي 1، نستنتج أن الدالة متوازنة.
إذن لنحسب احتمال الحصول على سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل
من القياسات.
وتبين أنها النتيجة الوحيدة السهلة حسابها فعلاً، لأن الجداء النقطي
الثنائي لسلسلة الأصفار بالكامل
مع أي سلسلة هو صفر. إذا فحصنا متجهنا
وفكرنا فيما يحدث عندما y تكون سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل،
نحصل على هذا التعبير هنا
لاحتمال الحصول على سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل
من القياسات.
وبالنظر في الحالتين الممكنتين حيث f ثابتة وf متوازنة، نرى أن احتمال
الحصول على سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل هو 1
في حالة أن f ثابتة، وصفر عندما f متوازنة.
عندما f ثابتة، المجموع يكون إما 2 أس
n أو سالب 2 أس n، وبالقسمة على 2 أس n
وأخذ مربع القيمة
المطلقة ينتج 1.
وعندما f متوازنة، المجموع يساوي 0.
ذلك لأننا سنحصل على
موجب 1 وسالب 1 عدداً متساوياً من المرات،
فتلغي بعضها جميعاً.
هذا كل شيء إذن. خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa
تحل مسألة Deutsch-Jozsa باستخدام استعلام واحد،
وليس هناك خطأ. بافتراض أن العمليات
تُجرى جميعها بشكل مثالي، تكون صحيحة في كل مرة.
فكيف يقارن ذلك بما
يمكننا فعله تقليدياً؟
حسناً، إذا أصررنا على
خوارزمية حتمية تحصل على الإجابة
الصحيحة في كل مرة، ففي أسوأ الحالات،
نحتاج 2 أس n ناقص 1 زائد 1 استعلام، وذلك لأنه يجب أن نستعلم عن الدالة
على أكثر من نصف مدخلاتها لنكون متأكدين من الحل.
حتى لو استعلمنا عن الدالة على 2 أس n ناقص 1
سلسلة مدخلات مختلفة، من الممكن أن نرى
نفس قيمة المخرج
في كل مرة، وقد يكون ذلك لأن
الدالة ثابتة، أو قد يكون أنها فعلاً متوازنة
وكنا فقط سيئي الحظ بشكل لا يُصدق حيث رأينا نفس قيمة المخرج
في كل مرة.
إذن تلك ميزة ضخمة
للكمي على التقليدي، استعلام واحد مقابل
عدد أسّي من الاستعلامات.
لكن، إذا استخدمنا
خوارزمية استعلام احتمالية وقبلنا احتمالاً صغيراً بأنها تجيب بشكل خاطئ،
فنحن فعلاً نحتاج فقط عدداً قليلاً من الاستعلامات.
بالتحديد، إذا
اخترنا عشوائياً k سلسلة وقيّمنا الدالة
على تلك السلاسل العشوائية،
فمن المرجح جداً أن نتمكن من معرفة الإجابة الصحيحة.
تحديداً، نجيب 0 أو ثابتة عندما نحصل على نفس قيمة الدالة
في كل مرة و1 أو متوازنة
عندما نرى قيمتي
دالة مختلفتين.
إذا فعلنا ذلك، سنكون دائماً على صواب عندما
تكون الدالة ثابتة لأنه بالطبع سنرى دائماً نفس
قيمة المخرج في هذه الحالة.
وإذا كانت f متوازنة، فمن المرجح جداً أن نرى
قيمتي مخرج مختلفتين.
احتمال عدم رؤية
كلتا قيمتي المخرج في هذه الحالة هو نفس احتمال قلب عملة معدنية k مرة
والحصول على نفس
النتيجة في كل مرة.
فمثلاً، إذا
جعلنا k تساوي 11، فاحتمال الحصول على إجابة خاطئة أقل من عُشر بالمئة.
فخصوصاً عندما نأخذ بعين الاعتبار أن الحواسيب الكمية لن تكون مثالية أبداً في الواقع، فنحن لا نحصل فعلاً على
ميزة كبيرة هنا،
لكننا نحرز تقدماً، ولدينا ميزة قابلة للقياس للكمي على التقليدي تتجاوز خوارزمية Deutsch.
يمكننا أيضاً استخدام دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa لحل مسألة استعلام مختلفة تُعرف بمسألة Bernstein-Vazirani.
إليكم صياغة تلك المسألة. المدخل هو دالة
من n بت إلى 1 بت، تماماً مثل مسألة Deutsch-Jozsa،
ومرة أخرى، إنها مسألة وعد.
هذه المرة، الوعد هو أنه توجد سلسلة n بت s بحيث الدالة f
تعمل كما ترون هنا،
حيث المخرج يُعطى
بالجداء النقطي الثنائي للمدخل مع هذه السلسلة s،
والهدف ببساطة
هو إيجاد السلسلة s. يمكننا أن نتخيل أن
السلسلة s مخفية بمعنى ما،
لكن يمكننا التعلم عنها
بإجراء استعلامات لـ f، وهدفنا هو إيجاد
هذه السلسلة المخفية.
للتوضيح، معظم الدوال
لن تستوفي هذا الوعد، لكن كالمعتاد، نحن نهتم فقط
بدوال المدخل التي تستوفيه.
كما اتضح، دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa تحل هذه المسألة فعلاً
مباشرة كما هي.
إذا شغّلناها لدالة
كالتي لدينا هنا والتي تستوفي
الوعد لسلسلة s ما، فالقياسات ستكشف السلسلة s
دون الحاجة لأي معالجة لاحقة.
إذن لنرَ كيف يعمل هذا.
لقد حللنا بالفعل
دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa، لذا يمكننا فعلاً القفز
مباشرة إلى النهاية.
إليكم التعبير الذي
كان لدينا سابقاً لحالة الـ qubits قبل القياسات مباشرة، وذلك التعبير كان
صالحاً لأي دالة f.
والآن، إذا عوّضنا
بما نحن موعودون به عن الدالة f وبسّطنا،
نحصل على حالة الناقص
للـ qubit السفلي منسورة بـ cat s للـ n qubits العلوية.
وهكذا نحصل على s عندما نقيس.
هناك بعض العمل اللازم لإجراء التبسيطات
التي عرضتها هنا، ولن أمر بذلك في هذا الفيديو،
لكن هناك تفصيل أكثر عن ذلك في محتوى الكتاب المدرسي لهذه السلسلة، والذي يمكنكم إيجاده بتتبع الرابط في وصف الفيديو،
أو جرّبوها بأنفسكم
كتمرين.
إذن ما وجدناه هو أن
دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa تحل مسألة Bernstein-Vazirani
باستعلام واحد.
ليس من الصعب إثبات
أن أي خوارزمية تقليدية، سواء كانت حتمية
أو احتمالية، تحتاج على الأقل n استعلام
لحل مسألة Bernstein-Vazirani للسبب البسيط أننا نحتاج n بت من
المعلومات لاسترجاع s،
وكل استعلام يعطينا على
الأكثر بتاً واحداً من المعلومات.
إذن نحصل على ميزة أخرى للكمي على التقليدي في
خوارزميات الاستعلام، استعلام واحد للخوارزميات الكمية،
n استعلام للخوارزميات التقليدية.
من المفيد التوقف لحظة للحديث عن
التسمية المُستخدمة في سياق هذه المسألة وقليلاً عن تاريخها.
أحياناً يُشير الناس إلى الخوارزمية التي وصفتها للتو باسم خوارزمية Bernstein-Vazirani، لكنها فعلاً مجرد
دائرة Deutsch-Jozsa،
وهذا شيء كان،
بالفعل، مذكوراً بوضوح شديد في عمل Bernstein وVazirani.
لذا من الغريب بعض الشيء أنها تُسمى خوارزمية
Bernstein-Vazirani لأنها تقريباً نفس الشيء مثل خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa
مطروحاً منها المعالجة اللاحقة. لكن Bernstein وVazirani ذهبا
خطوة أبعد فعلاً.
لقد عرّفا نسخة
تكرارية من هذه المسألة، حيث يتوجب عليك أساساً
حل حالات من مسألة Bernstein-Vazirani
لفتح حالات جديدة من المسألة مرتبة في نمط
شجري معقد.
إنها مسألة مصطنعة جداً، لكن النقطة هي أنه بتعريف
مسألة بهذه الطريقة، تمكنوا فعلياً من تمديد
الفصل بين واحد مقابل n استعلام بين الكمي والتقليدي.
وما حصلوا عليه هو
أول مثال معروف على ما يُسمى ميزة فوق-متعددة الحدود للكمي على الخوارزميات الاحتمالية.
هذه النسخة التكرارية من
مسألة Bernstein-Vazirani تبين أيضاً بعد ذلك بكثير
أنها مثيرة جداً للاهتمام في نظرية التعقيد
الحسابي لأسباب مختلفة.
على أي حال، النقطة هي أن
Bernstein وVazirani يستحقان بالتأكيد التقدير لمساهماتهم المهمة،
لكن ليس من المنطقي فعلاً
الإشارة إلى هذه باسم خوارزمية Bernstein-Vazirani، إنها أساساً مجرد
خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa.
في الجزء الأخير من الدرس، سنلقي نظرة على
خوارزمية استعلام كمية أخرى تُعرف بخوارزمية Simon.
سترون تشابهاً واضحاً
بين هذه الخوارزمية وخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa، لكنها مختلفة، والأهم من ذلك،
إنها تكشف عن ميزة أقوى بكثير للكمي على التقليدي في
خوارزميات الاستعلام.
تحديداً، تعطينا
ميزة أسّية مُثبتة للكمي على التقليدي، حتى الاحتمالية منها.
المسألة التي تحلها مصطنعة بعض الشيء، ومن الصعب تخيل موقف يكون فيه حل هذه
المسألة مفيداً،
لكنها ألهمت مباشرة
اكتشاف Peter Shor لخوارزمية كمية
لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل،
وهذا يدعم بقوة شديدة
فكرة نموذج الاستعلام كطبق بتري يمكن فيه تطوير الأفكار الخوارزمية
الكمية.
لنبدأ بمسألة الاستعلام التي تحلها خوارزمية Simon، والتي كما قد تكونون خمنتم،
تُسمى مسألة Simon.
إليكم صياغة المسألة، وسنحتاج لتفكيكها لفهم ما تتناوله.
أول شيء يُلاحَظ
هو أن هذه المرة، دالة المدخل f تربط سلاسل n
بت بسلاسل m بت
حيث m عدد صحيح موجب لا يساوي واحداً بشكل عام.
إنها مسألة وعد. ومثل مسألة Bernstein-Vazirani، الوعد يتضمن سلسلة s يمكننا اعتبارها سلسلة مخفية،
وأيضاً مثل مسألة
Bernstein-Vazirani، الهدف هو إخراج
هذه السلسلة المخفية s.
الوعد أكثر تعقيداً
هذه المرة، لذا لنفككه ونفهم
ما يقوله.
للبدء، لنقرأه فقط. يقول أنه توجد سلسلة s بطول يساوي n
بحيث أن شرط "إذا
وفقط إذا" معين صحيح لجميع اختيارات سلاسل n بت x وy.
تحديداً، يجب أن يكون
الحال أن f(x) تساوي f(y) إذا وفقط إذا تحقق أحد
احتمالين.
الاحتمال الأول هو أن x تساوي y، والاحتمال الثاني هو أنه بأخذ
eXclusive OR البتي لـ x
مع السلسلة المخفية s، نحصل على Y.
يتبين أن هذا
وعد صارم جداً بمعنى أن معظم
الدوال لن تستوفيه.
فقط دوال خاصة جداً
تستوفي هذا الشرط.
الآن، لنفهم هذا الوعد بشكل أفضل وبالتالي المسألة نفسها، سننظر في حالتين رئيسيتين.
الحالة الأولى هي أن s
هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل.
في هذه الحالة، يمكننا تبسيط عبارة "إذا
وفقط إذا" في الوعد لأن eXclusive OR
البتي لأي سلسلة x
مع سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل
هو ببساطة السلسلة x.
فيتبسط الشرط إلى
f(x) تساوي f(y) إذا وفقط إذا x تساوي y.
وهذا مجرد طريقة أخرى للقول أن f هي دالة أحادية.
بعبارة أخرى، السلسلة f(x) يجب أن تكون فريدة
لكل سلسلة x ممكنة.
فإذا كانت f دالة أحادية، فالوعد مستوفى فعلاً، تحديداً لـ s كونها
سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل،
وفي هذه الحالة، ذلك
هو المخرج الصحيح.
الحالة الثانية هي أن s
ليست سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، وما يعنيه ذلك هو أن الدالة f يجب أن تكون ثنائية إلى واحدة.
فلكل سلسلة مدخل x، هناك بالضبط سلسلة أخرى واحدة تربطها f بنفس
السلسلة التي ترتبط بها x،
وعلاوة على ذلك، السلسلة الأخرى
يجب أن تكون السلسلة التي نحصل عليها بأخذ eXclusive OR
البتي لـ x مع s.
طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك
هي أن كل سلسلة n بت x لها شريك، وذلك الشريك هو السلسلة التي نحصل عليها
بأخذ eXclusive OR البتي مع s.
أي شريكين يجب أن يعطيانا
نفس سلسلة المخرج إذا أدخلناهما في f، ولا يُسمح لأي سلاسل أخرى بأن تعطينا
نفس سلسلة المخرج تلك.
إذن هذه بالضرورة سلاسل مميزة ينتجها الشركاء.
إليكم مثالاً على دالة كهذه موصوفة بجدول قيمها.
إذن هذه دالة
من 3 بت إلى 5 بت.
إذا تأملنا جدول
القيم هذا لبعض الوقت، نجد أن الوعد مستوفى
للسلسلة 011.
000 و011 شريكان. تطبيق XOR على أي منهما
بـ s يعطينا الآخر،
وهما يأخذان نفس قيمة المخرج، وهي 10011 في هذه الحالة بالذات، ولا توجد سلاسل أخرى تُنتج
نفس سلسلة المخرج تلك.
001 و010 شريكان لأن تطبيق XOR على أي
منهما بـ s يعطي الآخر، وهما يُنتجان نفس قيمة المخرج،
والتي مرة أخرى، لا تُنتَج
من أي سلسلة أخرى.
والوضع مشابه
لـ 100 و111 وكذلك 101 و110.
فإذا كان المدخل للمسألة
هو هذه الدالة، فالإجابة الصحيحة هي السلسلة 011.
كما قلت سابقاً، معظم الدوال لا تستوفي هذا الوعد، إنه شرط محدد جداً.
يجب ملاحظة أيضاً أنه
إذا كان الوعد مستوفى، فلا يمكن استيفاؤه إلا لسلسلة s واحدة.
إذن هناك دائماً إجابة واحدة
صحيحة فقط لهذه المسألة.
إذن هذه هي مسألة Simon. كما قلت، من الصعب تخيل موقف عملي ترغب فيه بحل هذه المسألة،
لكن هذا ليس المهم. المهم هو محاولة معرفة ما تجيده الحواسيب الكمية، ويتبين أنها متفوقة بكثير
على الخوارزميات التقليدية في
حل هذه المسألة بالذات.
الآن لنلقِ نظرة
على خوارزمية Simon، التي تحل مسألة Simon.
الخوارزمية تتكون من
تشغيل الدائرة الكمية التي ترونها هنا عدة مرات، متبوعة بخطوة
معالجة لاحقة تقليدية،
وسنكون أكثر تحديداً بشأن ما تعنيه عدة
مرات بعد قليل.
الدائرة تبدو مشابهة جداً
لدائرة Deutsch-Jozsa، هذه المرة لأن الدالة
f تربط n بت بـ m بت،
بوابة الاستعلام مختلفة. بدلاً من مجرد qubit
واحد في الأسفل، لدينا الآن m qubit في الأسفل
وn في الأعلى كما سبق.
فرق أساسي هو أننا لا
نُعدّ حالة ناقص أو حالات ناقص متعددة في الأسفل.
هذه الـ qubits السفلية جميعها
مُهيّأة على حالة 0، وتلك الحالات تذهب مباشرة
إلى بوابة الاستعلام.
لذا لن يكون هناك أي ارتداد طور في هذه الخوارزمية، ببساطة ليست هكذا تعمل هذه الخوارزمية.
بخلاف الفروقات
التي ذكرتها للتو، تبدو مشابهة جداً
لدائرة Deutsch-Jozsa.
نُطبّق طبقة من بوابات Hadamard، ثم نُطبّق بوابة استعلام مرة واحدة، ثم نُطبّق طبقة
أخرى من بوابات Hadamard
متبوعة بقياسات أساس معياري للـ n qubits العلوية.
الفكرة هي أنه في كل مرة
نُشغّل هذه الدائرة ونقيس، سنحصل على سلسلة y تخبرنا شيئاً
عن السلسلة المخفية s
في مسألة Simon. وبتشغيل الدائرة
عدة مرات بشكل مستقل، سنكون قد جمعنا ما يكفي
من الأدلة الإحصائية عن s
لنتمكن من معرفة ما
هي بثقة عالية.
الآن لنحلل الدائرة الكمية
لخوارزمية Simon لنرى ما تفعله.
الحالة بعد الطبقة الأولى
من بوابات Hadamard تبدو هكذا، مشابهة لما كان لدينا
لخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa.
إلا أن هذه المرة، الـ m qubits السفلية جميعها في حالة 0
بدلاً من حالات الناقص.
بعد تطبيق بوابة الاستعلام، نرى أن القيمة f(x) قد كُتبت على
الـ m qubits السفلية أو الأكثر يساراً،
وذلك لأنه تم تطبيق XOR لـ f(x) على سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل.
إذن مرة أخرى، لا يحدث أي ارتداد طور في هذه الخوارزمية.
ثم نُطبّق الطبقة الثانية
من بوابات Hadamard.
وباستخدام نفس الصيغة السابقة لتأثير
طبقة من بوابات Hadamard على حالة أساس
معيارية، cat x في هذه الحالة،
كما كانت في الصيغة الأصلية، نحصل على هذه الحالة هنا، حيث تأثير بوابات Hadamard
أصبح أكثر وضوحاً. لكن إذا أردنا، يمكننا أيضاً كتابة الحالة
بشكل أكثر اختصاراً كما لدينا هنا.
في هذه المرحلة، نقيس الـ n qubits العلوية للحصول على سلسلة n بت y، ونحتاج فقط لمعرفة
ما هي الاحتمالات
للسلاسل المختلفة. وسيساعدنا ذلك في فهم
ما هي المعلومات التي نحصل عليها من هذه السلسلة y عن السلسلة s
المخفية داخل الدالة f.
سنحتاج مساحة أكبر
لهذا، ولا نحتاج فعلاً
مخطط الدائرة بعد الآن، لذا لنتخلص منه ونعطي أنفسنا مساحة
أكبر للتحليل.
إليكم الحالة قبل
القياسات مباشرة، وهي قياسات أساس معياري للـ n qubits العلوية أو الأكثر يميناً.
إذن القياس
يتوافق مع الـ cat الثاني.
لنُسمِّ p(y) الاحتمال بأن القياسات تعطينا السلسلة y لكل y ممكنة.
وإذا اتبعنا القواعد من الدرس 2، نحصل على أن كل من هذه الاحتمالات هو مربع النورم الإقليدي لأي متجه مُنسور
بحالة الأساس المعيارية،
المتوافقة مع y في
متجه حالتنا الكمية.
هذا يعطينا هذا التعبير هنا.
الآن، للحصول على فهم أفضل
لهذه الاحتمالات، سنحتاج لاستخدام
بعض الترميز، وقد تكونون بالفعل
مألوفين بهذا الترميز
لأنه شائع جداً في الرياضيات.
أولاً، عندما نشير إلى
مدى الدالة f، نعني ببساطة مجموعة كل السلاسل التي يمكن أن تخرج من هذه الدالة.
إذن هي مجموعة كل f(x) على جميع الاختيارات
الممكنة لسلسلة المدخل x.
ثانياً، سنستخدم هذا الترميز الذي ترونه هنا ليعني مجموعة كل سلاسل المدخل x
التي تربطها f بسلسلة مُعطاة z، لأي اختيار
لـ z نريد أخذه بعين الاعتبار.
يبدو كأنه
معكوس الدالة f، لكنه ليس فعلاً المعكوس لأن f ليست بالضرورة قابلة للعكس.
نرى أيضاً أن لدينا
مجموعة كوسيط على الطرف الأيسر، وفي هذه الحالة، إنها المجموعة المحتوية
فقط على السلسلة z الواحدة،
وهذا الدليل الذي نحتاجه للتعرف على أننا لا نتحدث عن
معكوس الدالة f، هذا يُسمى الصورة العكسية.
يمكن تعريف الصورة العكسية
بشكل أعم لأي مجموعة مُعطاة كوسيط، وليس فقط المجموعة المحتوية
على عنصر واحد،
لكن هذا كل ما سنحتاجه. إنه ليس أفضل
ترميز في العالم لأنه من السهل
الخلط بينه وبين المعكوس،
لكنه واضح بما فيه الكفاية
ومُستخدم على نطاق واسع، لذا سنمضي معه.
والآن إذا استخدمنا هذا الترميز، يمكننا إعادة كتابة المتجه الذي نأخذ
مربع نورمه الإقليدي للحصول على الاحتمال لقياس
كل سلسلة y.
نفعل هذا لأننا نحتاج لرؤية
ما هي المعاملات لكل حالة أساس معيارية فردية، وهذا غير واضح من
هذا التعبير هنا،
لأنه بشكل عام، قد
يكون لدينا خيارات متعددة لـ x تعطينا نفس السلسلة f(x).
في الجوهر، كل ما نفعله
هو تقسيم المجموع على x أولاً بالجمع على كل
z في مدى f،
وداخل ذلك المجموع، الجمع على كل x في الصورة العكسية لـ z، أو لنكون أدق،
الصورة العكسية للمجموعة
المحتوية على السلسلة z.
هذا يسمح لنا باستبدال f(x) بـ z داخل الـ cat هنا.
ومجموع كل السلاسل
المختلفة x التي تربطها f بكل z يُجمع في
المعامل لكل cat.
نحن أساساً نضع السلاسل في صناديق، نجمع على الصناديق، ثم نجمع على
السلاسل في كل صندوق،
لكن هذا مكافئ لمجرد
الجمع على كل السلاسل.
إذن نحصل على تعبير مكافئ للتعبير
الذي بدأنا به،
والآن يمكننا حساب
مربع النورم الإقليدي.
إنه مجرد مجموع مربعات القيم المطلقة
للمعاملات، وهكذا نحصل على هذا التعبير هنا
لاحتمالاتنا.
بالطبع، أعطوا أنفسكم
وقتاً للتحقق من هذا، إذا اخترتم فعل ذلك، يحتاج الأمر وقتاً للتعود على كل هذا
ولتتمكنوا من إجراء
هذه الحسابات، وكلما تمرنتم أكثر، أصبح الأمر أسهل.
حتى الآن، لم نستخدم
فعلاً الوعد في مسألة Simon على الإطلاق.
تحليلنا لهذه الاحتمالات يعمل فعلاً لأي دالة f، لكن الآن حان الوقت للتفكير في مسألة
Simon تحديداً.
سنقسّم الأمور إلى نفس الحالتين
اللتين كانتا لدينا سابقاً.
الحالة الأولى هي أن s
هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، والحالة الثانية هي أن
s ليست سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل.
في الحالة الأولى، أن
s هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، الأمور بسيطة جداً.
في هذه الحالة، كما رأينا سابقاً، لدينا أن f هي دالة أحادية، لذا هناك سلسلة x واحدة
يتم ربطها بكل من
السلاسل z في مدى f.
هذا يجعل مربع القيمة المطلقة للمجموع على تلك السلاسل يساوي 1 لأن هناك
حداً واحداً فقط في المجموع،
وهو إما موجب 1 أو سالب 1، لكن لا يهم أيهما لأننا نأخذ
مربع القيمة المطلقة، وهكذا نحصل على واحد.
هناك 2 أس n عنصر
في مدى f، ونعرف ذلك لأن f أحادية، لذا هناك سلسلة واحدة في
المدى لكل سلسلة مدخل.
وإذا قيّمنا التعبير بالكامل، نجد أن كل سلسلة y تظهر باحتمال
واحد على 2 أس n.
أو بعبارة أخرى،
القياسات تعطينا سلسلة y مختارة بشكل منتظم عشوائياً.
قد لا يبدو ذلك مفيداً جداً، لكننا سنتمكن فعلاً من
تمييز هذا السلوك عن السلوك الذي نحصل عليه في حالة
أن s ليست سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، وسنرى كيف يسير ذلك قريباً.
في الوقت الحالي، نلاحظ ببساطة أنه إذا
استوفت f الوعد في مسألة Simon في حالة أن s هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل،
فنتيجة القياسات هي سلسلة عشوائية منتظمة.
الآن لننتقل إلى الحالة الثانية، وهي أن الوعد
مستوفى لسلسلة s ليست سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل.
في هذه الحالة، كما ناقشنا سابقاً، كل سلسلة z في مدى f لها بالضبط سلسلتان مرتبطتان بها،
لأن كل سلسلة لها شريك، وكل زوج من الشركاء
يرتبط بسلسلة فريدة، وتحديداً، شريك كل سلسلة
هو السلسلة التي نحصل عليها بتطبيق XOR مع s.
فإذا اخترنا أي سلسلة
z في مدى f، وأعطينا الاسم w لأي من
السلسلتين اللتين ترتبطان بـ z عبر f،
فإن XOR لـ w مع s هو
السلسلة الأخرى التي ترتبط بـ z.
بالنظر إلى الحد الواحد فقط في مجموعنا الذي يتوافق مع أي سلسلة z في المدى التي لدينا في ذهننا،
نرى أنه يمكننا
كتابته بشكل أكثر وضوحاً كما لدينا هنا.
لدينا سلسلتان في الصورة العكسية لـ z، هما w وw مُطبّق عليها XOR مع s.
إذن يمكننا كتابة المجموع
كما ترون على الشاشة، والآن ما يمكننا فعله هو سحب عامل
سالب 1 أس w.y.
ذلك العامل سيكون
إما موجب 1 أو سالب 1، لذا يختفي عندما
نأخذ القيمة المطلقة،
وما يتبقى لدينا هو
هذا التعبير هنا.
التفاصيل ليست كلها موضحة هنا، وليس بالضرورة
واضحاً أنه يعمل بهذا الشكل، لكن يمكنكم التحقق من أن هذين
التعبيرين متساويان
بالعودة إلى تعريف
الجداء النقطي الثنائي والتفكير فيما يحدث عندما تكون هذه الأشياء في
أس سالب 1،
بشكل لا يختلف كثيراً عما كان
لدينا لمسألة Bernstein-Vazirani.
أخيراً، يمكننا تقسيم هذا
التعبير إلى حالتين.
يساوي 4 عندما الجداء النقطي
الثنائي لـ s وy يساوي 0، ويساوي 0 عندما الجداء النقطي
الثنائي لـ s وy يساوي 1.
لاحظوا بالتحديد أنه
لا يوجد أي اعتماد هنا على w أو z، إنه يعتمد فقط على s وy.
سبب حدوث ذلك هو
الطبيعة المحددة جداً والخاصة للوعد.
في الجوهر، هذا هو السبب في صياغة الوعد بهذه الطريقة، حتى تسير الأمور كلها هكذا.
مرة أخرى، كل سلسلة لها شريك، نحصل عليه بتطبيق XOR مع
هذه السلسلة المخفية الواحدة s،
وهذا ما يجعل كل هذا يحدث.
يمكننا الآن العودة إلى
تعبير الاحتمالات والتعويض.
عندما s ليست سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، هناك 2 أس n ناقص 1
عنصر في مدى f،
وهو نصف عدد
سلاسل المدخل، والتعويض
بالقيم التي حسبناها للتو يعطي هذه الصيغة هنا.
إذن هذه المرة، y ليست
سلسلة عشوائية تماماً، بل y منتظمة على نصف سلاسل n بت بالضبط،
وتحديداً، هي منتظمة
على تلك السلاسل التي لها جداء نقطي
ثنائي يساوي 0 مع s.
الآن بعد أن عرفنا كيف تعمل الدائرة
لخوارزمية Simon وتحديداً ما
هي الاحتمالات لنتائج القياس المختلفة،
يبقى أن نشرح كيف يساعدنا هذا في حل مسألة Simon.
لتلخيص ما تعلمناه للتو، إذا كان الحال أن الدالة f تستوفي الوعد في مسألة Simon،
عندما السلسلة المخفية s
هي سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، نحصل على سلسلة عشوائية
تماماً من القياسات،
حيث كل سلسلة n بت
y محتملة بالتساوي.
من ناحية أخرى، إذا استوفت الدالة f الوعد لسلسلة s مختلفة، واحدة لا تساوي
سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل،
فنحصل على سلسلة عشوائية y لها جداء نقطي ثنائي
يساوي 0 مع s، ومن بين كل تلك السلاسل،
كل y محتملة بالتساوي.
لكننا لن نحصل أبداً على سلسلة y لها جداء نقطي ثنائي
يساوي 1 مع s.
يصبح السؤال، "هل هذه معلومات كافية
لتحديد s؟" والإجابة، كما
أشرت بالفعل، هي نعم،
بشرط أن نُشغّل
الدائرة مرات كافية.
تحديداً، لنفترض
أننا نُشغّل الدائرة k مرة، حيث K تساوي n زائد r،
حيث r هو عدد سيتحكم في
احتمال استرجاعنا لـ s.
كمثال فقط، إذا
اخترنا r ليكون 10، سننجح باحتمال
أكبر من 99.9%،
لذا لا نحتاج r أن يكون كبيراً جداً.
بشكل عام، احتمال الفشل أقل من احتمال
قلب عملة عادلة r مرة والحصول على وجه في كل مرة.
فإذا لم يكن 99.9% كافياً
بالنسبة لكم، فاجعلوا r تساوي 20، واحتمال الفشل
أقل من واحد في المليون،
أو اختاروا أي r
يُريحكم. لا يمكنكم ضمان حل صحيح، لكن يمكنكم جعل
احتمال الخطأ ضئيلاً
لجميع الأغراض العملية.
هنا نُسمّي هذه
السلاسل y1 حتى yk، حيث نستخدم رموزاً علوية لمساعدتنا في تسمية هذه السلاسل،
فقط حتى نتمكن من حجز الرموز السفلية للإشارة إلى البتات
الفردية لتلك السلاسل.
إذن هذه ليست أسساً
أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل، هذه مجرد الأسماء التي نعطيها لهذه السلاسل k.
كل واحدة بطول n لأننا حصلنا عليها
من تشغيل دائرة خوارزمية Simon.
إذن يمكننا كتابة
البتات الفردية لهذه السلاسل k كما ترون هنا.
ما نفعله الآن هو إنشاء مصفوفة m، حيث كل مدخل في هذه المصفوفة هو بت، ونحصل على هذه البتات من السلاسل
التي قسناها للتو، تماماً كما هو موضح هنا.
إذن هذه المصفوفة لها k صف وn عمود، ومدخلاتها جميعها قيم ثنائية.
الآن، لا نعرف ما هي s. هذا ما نحاول إيجاده، لكن تخيلوا للحظة أننا
عرفنا s فعلاً،
وشكّلنا متجه عمود
من بتات s، تماماً كما هو موضح هنا.
إذا ضربنا ذلك المتجه بـ m ثم أخذنا النتيجة معامل-2، أو طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك
هي أننا نستبدل الجمع
بـ eXclusive OR، فسنحصل بالضرورة
على متجه الأصفار بالكامل.
ذلك لأن كل مدخل
في هذا المتجه الناتج ليس سوى الجداء النقطي الثنائي لـ s
مع أحد صفوف m.
إذا كانت S صدفةً سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، سنحصل دائماً على متجه الأصفار من الجداء النقطي الثنائي.
وإذا لم تكن s سلسلة الأصفار بالكامل، سنحصل على هذا مما
نعرفه عن الاحتمالات لظهور السلاسل y1 حتى yk.
بالتحديد، الجداء النقطي
الثنائي مع s دائماً صفر لكل هذه السلاسل.
طريقة بسيطة لقول ذلك هي أن هذا المتجه
المُشكّل من بتات s دائماً في الفضاء
الصفري للمصفوفة m،
بافتراض أننا نجري كل
حساباتنا معامل-2، لكن بالطبع، لا نعرف ما هي s،
نحن نحاول إيجاد s.
لكن ما يمكننا فعله هو حساب
الفضاء الصفري لهذه المصفوفة m، مرة أخرى، معامل-2.
تحديداً، يمكننا فعل ذلك باستخدام تقنية
الحذف الغاوسي، وهو الإجراء الذي يُدرّس غالباً
في مقررات الجبر الخطي التمهيدية.
إنه يعمل بشكل مثالي عندما نجري كل حساباتنا معامل-2، ويمكن إجراؤه بكفاءة
عالية بالحاسوب.
وإذا حسبنا الفضاء الصفري لـ m، بالنظر إلى الطريقة المحددة التي اختيرت بها هذه السلاسل k
عشوائياً،
سنتمكن من استرجاع s باحتمال أكبر من
1 ناقص 2 أس سالب r.
لنكون محددين، ما سنراه باحتمال أكبر من
1 ناقص 2 أس سالب r هو أن الفضاء الصفري
يتضمن متجه الأصفار بالكامل،
كما يحدث دائماً لكل مصفوفة، وكذلك المتجه المتوافق مع s، سواء كان متجه الأصفار بالكامل أم لا.
والأهم من ذلك، لن تظهر أي متجهات أخرى
في الفضاء الصفري.
ليس من الصعب فعلاً إثبات هذا، رغم أنني لن أمر بالتفاصيل.
الفكرة هي أنه إذا
كانت لدينا سلسلة أخرى ليست متجه الأصفار
بالكامل وليست s، فكل واحدة من السلاسل العشوائية
y1 حتى yk،
ستقوم أساساً بإقصائها
من الفضاء الصفري باحتمال النصف.
فبعد k لقطة، ليس من المرجح
أبداً أن تبقى، وفي الواقع، لا شيء من
السلاسل التي لا تنتمي
من المرجح أن يبقى. وحقيقة بسيطة جداً
من نظرية الاحتمالات، تُعرف بحد الاتحاد، يمكن
استخدامها لإثبات ذلك.
لم أشرح كل
التفاصيل هنا، لكن آمل أن تكونوا قد فهمتم الفكرة أنه بحساب الفضاء
الصفري معامل-2 لهذه المصفوفة m،
من المرجح جداً أن نسترجع s، وهكذا تحل خوارزمية Simon
مسألة Simon.
هناك شيء واحد أخير
يجب قوله عن مسألة Simon، ويتعلق بالصعوبة
التقليدية لهذه المسألة،
أي كم استعلاماً تحتاج خوارزمية استعلام تقليدية لحل مسألة Simon؟
الإجابة هي، الكثير، بشكل عام.
هناك عبارات دقيقة مختلفة
يمكن صياغتها حول الصعوبة التقليدية
لهذه المسألة، وإليكم واحدة منها.
إذا كانت لدينا أي خوارزمية
استعلام احتمالية وتلك الخوارزمية تُجري أقل من 2 أس n على 2
ناقص 1، ناقص 1 استعلام،
وهذا عدد من الاستعلامات
أسّي في n، فإن تلك الخوارزمية ستفشل
في حل مسألة Simon،
باحتمال لا يقل عن النصف.
أحياناً، إثبات
نتائج الاستحالة كهذه يمكن أن يكون تحدياً كبيراً، لكن هذه ليست صعبة جداً لإثباتها
من خلال تحليل
احتمالي أولي.
لن أفعل ذلك في درس الفيديو هذا، وسأركز فقط بدلاً من ذلك
على الحدس وراءه.
نحن نحاول إيجاد السلسلة المخفية s، لكن طالما لم نستعلم عن الدالة على سلسلتين لهما
نفس قيمة المخرج،
سنحصل على معلومات
محدودة جداً عن s.
أساساً، كل ما نتعلمه هو
أن السلسلة المخفية s ليست eXclusive OR لأي سلسلتين مميزتين
استعلمنا عنهما،
وإذا استعلمنا عن الدالة بأقل من هذا العدد من الاستعلامات، سيظل هناك الكثير من اختيارات s
التي لم يتم استبعادها.
هذا ليس برهاناً رسمياً،
لكن هذه هي الفكرة الأساسية.
فباختصار، خوارزمية Simon تمنحنا ميزة مذهلة للكمي على التقليدي
ضمن نموذج الاستعلام.
بالتحديد، خوارزمية Simon
تحل مسألة Simon بعدد من الاستعلامات خطي في عدد بتات المدخل
n لدالتنا،
بينما أي خوارزمية تقليدية،
حتى لو كانت احتمالية، تحتاج لإجراء عدد
من الاستعلامات أسّي في n
لحل مسألة Simon باحتمال نجاح معقول.
صحيح أن مسألة Simon هي مسألة مصطنعة إلى حد ما ولا يريد أحد
فعلاً حلها على الأرجح،
لكن ذلك ثانوي. أحياناً تحتاج الأفكار أن تُطوَّر قبل أن تُوضع موضع التطبيق.
وفعلاً، صرّح Peter Shor بوضوح أن خوارزمية Simon هي التي ألهمت خوارزميته الشهيرة الآن
لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل، والتي سنراها في درسين لاحقين.
وهذه نهاية الدرس 5.
في هذا الدرس، ألقينا نظرة على
نموذج الاستعلام للحوسبة، ورأينا تسلسلاً من الأمثلة
على خوارزميات كمية
تُظهر مزايا على الخوارزميات التقليدية
ضمن هذا النموذج.
هناك بالفعل الكثير
المعروف عن نموذج الاستعلام والخوارزميات الكمية لمسائل أخرى
لم أناقشها.
فإذا وجدتم هذا
النموذج مثيراً للاهتمام، هناك الكثير
لتتعلموه عنه.
خطوتنا التالية ستكون الانتقال
بعيداً عن نموذج الاستعلام ونحو نموذج للحوسبة
أكثر تمثيلاً
لأنواع المسائل التي قد نأمل في حلها عملياً.
آمل أن تنضموا إليّ في الدرس 6، حيث سنركز بشكل رئيسي على
وضع أساس لدراسة الخوارزميات الكمية.
ومن هناك، سننتقل إلى بعض
الخوارزميات الكمية المحددة، بما في ذلك خوارزمية Shor
لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل
في الدروس اللاحقة. إلى اللقاء حتى ذلك الحين!